let's take a quick look of how to set
your scanner settings that is to set it
for a particular DPI so what you do is
you first take a preview at least on my
scanner this is the software that I see
yours might be different but the idea is
the same so we get a preview this is
what what my screen looks like and what
I decided to do is scan only this
particular portion to get final images
of this particular device so I did that
that's how it looks and when I press
scan I am asked whether I want to save
it and I didn't intend to save it at 72
DPI that's the first scan that I decided
to take and then I went through a whole
series of various scans and let's look
at them all together the various scans
were 72 DPI 324 hundred up to 60 400 DPI
and let's see the difference here it is
slightly enlarged sort of trying to keep
the same visuals for you to compare I'm
starting to see that the 72 DPI is
definitely losing clarity the others
look okay and as we increase the images
more so we're starting to see this one
breaking down and it's starting to
really show up as we increase the image
size so you see as you increase the
resolution you get more clarity in the
image you're getting more information
for the most part